20-17 has been one of the craziest years
in the eSports history Baker is
destroyed just this year we've had more
than a dozen non-endemic investors buy
into eSports the announcement and
creation of a franchised na LCS and a
total shift in the dota 2 pro system but
we also saw the implosion of a major
eSports team and scandals that brought
back memories of how eSports was before
the scene was professionalized 2017 was
a transitional year it was a year
removed further away from the grassroots
origins of eSports and further into a
professionalized model designed to
attract outside money and viewers into
the scene but it was also a year rocked
by scandals deals gone wrong and an
entire league being left out to dry
20:17 proved that eSports is growing but
it hasn't gone past growing pains just
yet
in January we began to see the first
signs of investment from non-endemic
sports organizations into eSports the
Miami Heat entered into a strategic
partnership with misfits which is so far
seen misfits players show up at the
heats NBA games and misfits itself get a
spot in the overwatch league the Heat
weren't the only pro sports team to
invest into eSports this month either as
Milwaukee Bucks co-owner Wesley Eden's
also founded fly quest in January
speaking of eSports teams expanding echo
Fox signed the majority of their
all-star fighting game roster this month
including future Evo champion Hajime
taquito Taniguchi and more Kombat star
Dominique Sonic Fox McLain finally right
at the end of January a straw Louis won
the first csgo major of the year with a
2-1 win over virtus Pro and it
the poem has been picked up by Dupree
they got the spray Neal takes one in
town today an astronomer in the first
major championship
16:14 against unbelievable February was
a pretty slow month but in more sports
orgs are buying up East for steams News
Delaware North purchased a controlling
stake in splice February did however
bring the first major scandal of the
year as tainted mines coach Nick and
Aerosmith came forward with allegations
that his team was being mistreated by
their organization cetain and mines was
a huge story this year and it was drawn
out over several months over several
reports basically boiled down to an
oceanic League of Legends team tainted
mines and the way in which it was
treating its players it started with an
arrow basically coming forward and
telling the public through a twit longer
that there were terrible conditions in
the team house there were allegations
that air conditioning wasn't working and
this was summer in Australia that there
were insufficient computers for them to
practice that garbage was piling up in
the house because basically there wasn't
enough city sponsored trash bins to
collect all the trash there were all of
these problems and that the team was
basically locked in a contract dispute
the players rather that were locked in a
contract dispute with tainted mines over
the course of the next couple of months
we spoke to many of the players we spoke
to their manager who outlined a lot of
the problems they'd had with the
organization ultimately all of this
culminates in a riot investigation into
the team the tainted mines saga
continued into March but as it did the
rest of eSports kept moving to Team
Liquid began to shuffle around their
league of legends roster this month
bringing on
Yuliang double lift pang to save them
from relegation putting rookie ad carry
young young bin young bin out of a job
man that organization has had a history
it seems like with Steve Aaron set he's
been he's been a great boss it seems
like he does
we care about his players but the team
itself doesn't seem to know how to
manage their roster or pick players and
their teamwork isn't really good they
seem to always want to find the quickest
solution and so they put money into
places that would get them that bandy
solution but then it doesn't always work
out so this year we saw them you know
they got rain over who was freaking good
in it or Europe or mortals like he's
amazing but some reason he just fell
through it in liquid this liquid just
seemed to like Breen players piglet I
don't know
also in March optic gaming won the 2017
halo World Championship with a 400 sweep
over team Envy simp we're taking a look
at the end of this game McQueen
recognizing that everyone's over
gentlemen optic gaming eye of 2017 hey
champions
moving on to April we saw Team solomid
win the NA LCS spring finals in
Vancouver
while origin the team founded by
legendary League of Legends mid laner
Enric a expec a Cedeno Martinez was
relegated from the EU LCS after split
after split of poor performances Origen
get three odes origins nightmare come to
an end as Giants keep their LCS dream
alive but the most important thing that
happened in April was that the score
eSports broke the news that Riot Games
was franchising the NA LCS which had
wide reaching implications across all of
eSports for the rest of the year and
definitely beyond that I think any LCS
franchising is probably still the
biggest story of the year for me at
least basically with a move towards a
franchise model ride is trying to
duplicate with League of Legends what
traditional sports leagues have done and
they're trying to create basically an
ecosystem in North America where the
investors the sponsors the teams all
feel comfortable and feel like they can
experiment basically going back even
before this year we heard obviously from
basically every LCS team owner that they
were unable to turn a profit with their
teams that because of the way that the
na and EU LCS were set up they were
losing money it wasn't a successful
venture and that this was scaring away
sponsors sponsors who didn't want to
invest in teams that like a were unable
to turn a profit but be also the fear of
relegation with a franchise system teams
can bring in players and and not be
afraid they can take some time to
develop talent and rookies and it
basically just gives everyone a safety
cushion to really focus on being the
best teams that they can rather than
just staying out of relegation
guaranteeing that performance but to
split also this month the International
2016 champions wing
Gaming left their organization following
reports that players weren't paid on
time and that the organization took the
majority of their prize money the
players formed team random but collapsed
in May after a last place finish at the
Kyiv major and have since scattered
across several Chinese teams they ripped
down the tier 3 Tower
whee-ha was to go through the back
International 2016 champion
fingers
[Applause]
Wanda techies nothing else happened in
me so let's skip that in favor of
something more exciting June picked off
with Riot Games officially announcing
that na LCS franchising was happening
detailing the application process and
revealing that they would kickstart a
players association to advocate for na
LCS Pro also this month we saw a lot of
colleagues lose their jobs when Yahoo
eSports shut down following Verizon's
acquisition of Yahoo several former
Yahoo eSports writers and staff found
new homes elsewhere but unfortunately it
wasn't the last time an eSports news
site shut down this year moving on to
July League of Legends franchising saw
its first result as the Madison Square
Garden company bought CLG adding yet
another sports org to the LCS then just
ahead of the international valve
released their plan to change the dota
pro circuit adding several more majors
and minors any Bowser's rework of the
major/minor system is a new system by
which teams will be determined to play
at the international but also support
third party tournament organizers in the
dota team so any tournament that has a
minimum required pipe prize pool will be
either assigned as a major or a minor by
valve and have an additional prize pool
equivalent to that supplemented to the
tournament's it's a big deal because in
a lot of ways it kind of gives back a
lot of power to the tournament
organisers this is something that
they've been talking about a lot of
majors though the majors have been
organized by third party companies there
were only so many of them but now it's a
major the new major minor systems many
more are representing valve and dota
competitions new companies are
representing it as well in tournament
wins this month
gambit won the major with a shock
2-1 victory over immortals propelled by
the best grenade throw in major history
the gambit is done even more firepower
that's bring more huge Georgie stone
into the corner
smart also this month we saw Hajime
Tokyo Taniguchi Adam Armada Lindgren and
Salim Salem a Kia young crowd Evo
champions in evo 2017 s3 biggest
tournaments so Tokyo winning Evo I think
the reaction was like jubilation at
least that's what I was seeing
Tokyo is beloved mainstay of the fgc of
street fighter specifically I mean if
you talk to someone who loves fighting
games and they don't love taquito
I would have some questions for that
person he had an incredible loser's
bracket won't run through he bow and he
came up against the most promising young
player of this year I think it would be
difficult to dispute Punk in the grand
finals and punk had so much hype so much
heat going into that Tokyo comes in with
a character that by some accounts is not
quite an st ER or an a to your character
not quite up to par in the form of Akuma
and some people myself included had some
doubts whether that character could
carry Tokyo to where he needed to be to
where his skill was as a player he was
in his element it was a legendary win I
think the reaction was just was
jubilation
finally he's been chasing it for so long
our mother winning evo I think was
obviously was a big deal for him you
know and that it's he's he finally has
that second Evo he can he can work
towards the three-peat he's tied with
mango for Evo wins and and that kind of
kind of evens up that rivalry or really
pushes it in favor of Armada it was a
cap to an incredible season Parramatta
following you know his loss to hungrybox
in 2016 that was sort of a very big
emotional moment for Mata as he told me
and I think that after that he was that
what a fire under him to just win
everything that he did he was the
undisputed best in the world by the end
of 2016 and going into 2017 evo 2017
that was our modest tournament oh my god
dad see the repeat of Row three one-hour
pada finally this month we saw the first
seven overwatch League team owners
announced missed it's immortals energy
Patriots owner Robert Kraft New York
Mets CEO Jeff Wilpon Chinese game
publisher
Nettie's and korean-american eSports org
ksv took the first seven spots August
brought ti7
we're Team Liquid won a hard-earned 3o
victory over newbie to take home the
aegis
[Applause]
[Music]
also this month optic gaming defeated
team envy to take home the 2017 Call of
Duty World Championship
[Applause]
finally in August we got a few more
overwatch League teams in cloud nine and
the Kroenke family which owns the LA
Rams the Denver Nuggets and Arsenal
moving on to September we saw the final
overwash League team owners announced
optic gaming team NV and Comcast
Spectacor which owns the Philadelphia
Flyers bought in completing the 12 team
initial lineup the kinds of
organizations and investors who seen buy
into the overwatch leading kind of fills
me and I think some people with a lot of
hope regarding the V for eSports we've
seen a lot and I mean a lot of
traditional sports investors get into
eSports in last year across with League
of Legends an overwatch do virtually has
a few though kind of for my taste not
quite enough traditional eSports endemic
teams involved it's got venture
capitalists investors in it's got sort
of a wide array and diverse array of
investment in it which is really
interesting exciting to see I think with
League of Legends right now we're
basically only seeing eSports teams and
sports teams so saying also that mix of
VC money is really cool the best
practices of time-honored traditional
sports helped to define the unique
structure of the overwatch league our
goal is to create the world's premier
eSport League where teams and players
can thrive for years to come and fans
are made for life also this month
h2k gaming co-chair Richard lippy
released a statement threatening to have
h2k leave the EU LCS if significant
changes weren't made to the system for
the 2018 season the u LCS is basically
to put it bluntly in shambles viewership
in EU is lower than it has been for a
long time and we've seen a lot of
concerns about that over a pretty long
period of time but also riot just seems
to be unsure about what they want to do
with Europe I think and we've spoken to
a lot of European you know coaches team
owners and players and a lot of people
feel like riot is just experimenting
with the u LCS Europe has been through
so many sort of
diverse attempts at making this region
work we went to best of two's for a
while and then probably the biggest
example of riots inability to decide
what they want to do with Europe came in
the reported alternative format for 2018
which was 24 teams spread out across
many regions basically we would have a
series of national leagues and then one
larger league to mirror the European
football space also in September the
biggest csgo story of the year broke
immortals csgo team showed up late to
their grand finals game at dreamhack
Montreal immortals made it to the grand
finals of Dreamhack Montreal facing
north three of their players KNG Henny
and Lucas failed to show up at the
designated time for said grand finals
they were then by Dreamhack given a
disqualification for the first map of
that best of three grand finals meaning
North effectively just won the first map
by default we will not be seeing the
first map of Mirage it does look like
the immortals have forfeited it due to
being late to the stage and to playing
and that's just the way the cookie
crumbled I suppose I don't really know
what else to say about that other than
the process needs to be respected they
did show up late and played the second
map it was cobblestone and it was North
that was a wrap we had a grand finals
that was one map the trade though and
immortals with an entry chance confit
goes down
the chance
[Music]
John and in one map they went a
best-of-three that's right because for
gifted the first one and they clean up
let that not be an asterisk beside
North's performance however they were
excellent throughout this whole event it
would have been a challenge for
immortals either way and then Vito can G
Giuseppe made some death threats I think
it was Ryu actually that said something
about some of the immortals players
being out late last night partying and
then after this after that tweeted that
GOG lost two immortals in the bracket
before saying that his only like his
regret was like not only the leaves but
he lost to like hungover players or
something like that it was seen by Kenji
and he responded with prove it or I'll
kill you
I think the community reaction towards
immortals as an organisation is that
they've handled it professionally no
it's handled it professionally after
losing the first map against CLG using
our coach as a stand-in penny and Lucas
refused to continue playing the match
unless KNG was allowed to play as a
member of the starting roster with KNG
playing we took the next two maps and
the match but can G being included in
the starting roster was a direct
violation of the punishment that we had
communicated to him and the players less
than a day earlier for violating that
punishment Kenji was immediately
terminated from his contract and it's
not a part of immortals and will never
again be a part for the laws after
stealing bolts left and things really
crumbled I feel like the sentiment was
just oh my god we feel so bad for morals
I can't believe this happened it was
like getting hit with one blow after
another it was almost a joke right
what's gonna go wrong next what's gonna
what's gonna happen with immortals next
that's gonna collapse their roster for
the umpteenth time
immortals Oslo collapse continued over
the next few months as the teams signed
on more players and shed old once they
had lost their major spot which was a
huge hit to the organization and things
were only going to get worse for
immortals but before that happened
tober came around and brought even more
instability to the LCS unicorns of love
CEO Yas Milan released an open letter in
which he stated that the current system
just wasn't viable for smaller teams
like his that can't afford to take huge
losses every year the same day paris
anime dropped out of League of Legends
marking a huge blow to the future of EU
League of Legends Paris an German and
Schalke little film are gonna make it to
an au-pair e Sanja man lose it in extra
time Schalke no fear Pro the final
whistle on Paris an Germans challenger
series campaign they were so close and
then November happened riot responded to
the EU LCS doom saying by claiming that
they were exploring the possibility of
franchising in 2019 and that relegation
would be removed in 2018 it's still
unclear what will happen but all the
current EU LCS teams are still signed on
for another season
so the situation seems to have calmed
down at least for now obviously I don't
know what it's like to work for ride and
the regions are very different but it
seems like Europe has been shafted in
the franchising situation but maybe
franchising will work for Europe I don't
know but it seems like a lot of the pros
in Europe they have a lot of pride and I
think a lot of the players that I've
talked to you like for example fanatics
like so as I've spoken to him and a lot
of reckless I've spoken to him like they
seem to have a lot of pride in staying
in Europe despite the fact that the
finance might not be as good over in
North America though right announced the
10 na LCS teams bringing on the
Cleveland Cavaliers back to 100 thieves
the Golden State Warriors golden
Guardians the Houston rocket run clutch
gaming and optic gaming that left team
envy Phoenix one dignitas and perhaps
most notably immortals out in the cold
that wasn't great for a world we still
don't know everything that happened
during the franchising application
process we've done quite a bit of
reporting on it but everything is
cloaked in NDA
that are still active you know teams
can't really tell us exactly what went
down
and basically what riot has told us
about immortal specifically is that they
were unhappy with their books that
immortals were operating too big a loss
and that riot was on unwilling I guess
to partner with them moving forward
given the financial troubles that that
team was having in more positive news
Dallas Cowboys owner Jerry Jones
purchased complexity gaming marking the
last of over a dozen non-endemic
investors buying into major eSports
teams this year in tournament news we
saw gale force esports wind the our LCS
season four finals with a 400 win over
method and hungrybox win smashed some at
five
the last major melee tournament of the
year ending armadas dominant streak at
summit events just wait for it bill and
hungrybox ends the armada streak 5
champion hungrybox winning summit was
sort of the final nail in the coffin
that ended armadas stranglehold on the
position of best player in melee that
was sort of back and forth in 2016 but
our modest you know nonstop wins aside
from Evo really kind of put it in
armadas favor going out of evo everybody
thought you know best player in the
world Armada there is no question but
hungrybox is incredible dominance
meeting just about everybody over the
last you know six seven months has been
unbelievable to watch and him beating
Armada in the grand finals of summit
really said hungrybox is the best player
in the world and of course November
brought us the League of Legends World
Championships where Samsung Galaxy
shocked the world with upset after upset
to take home the summoner's Cup
[Applause]
their 2017 champion
so Samsung as a team have been in what
has felt like a rebuild since the end of
2014 at the end of 2014 Samsung
obviously Samsung white won the world
championship Samsung blue the sister
team looked like one of the strongest
teams in the region and after that all
ten players starting players from both
teams left the region as part of the
Korean Exodus Samsung was forced to
rebuild and through 2015
they seemed almost insignificant in the
Korean scene they didn't have strong
performances at all
but they were slowly putting together
this roster that was really able to
compete with some of the top teams with
SKT with long Jiu in 2017 and heading
into the summer split basically it
seemed like Samsung was able to be one
of the strongest teams in the region but
a lot of people still expected them not
to go to Worlds a lot of people expected
kt rolster to go to Worlds instead of
samsung faker has built a reputation for
himself in the past few years being the
deep the unkillable demon and I don't
know even seeing him he always seemed
kind of monotone getting the chance to
interview him he did have like moments
of like you know personality that came
out but to the public I think generally
people saw him as almost stoic and
unapproachable you know he kind of had
that reputation so the moment you saw
him actually break down on stage after
losing to Samsung
he was a person he's a kid he's a kid
people forget that someone who's won
worlds three times it's just the kid
that's probably one of the most
important images are like moments in
eSports at least the League of Legends
for the year following their win the
Samsung Galaxy roster was purchased by
ksv the company that owns the Seoul
dynasty and ksv black butt November
wasn't all happy news counter logic
gaming dropped their mail csgo rosters
with reports stating that the team had
ongoing financial issues
in December the immortal saga finally
came to an end as Lucas 110:1 and
cangjie signed with hundred thieves
bringing immortals major spot with them
December capped off the year with plenty
of tournaments MK leo won the - GG
circuit championship Menna rd1 the
Capcom Cup in a complete upset and kt
rolster won the Kaspar Kordes
[Applause]
december is always a quiet month for big
news in eSports but LCS teams finished
off finalizing their rosters the
overwatch League preseason kicked off
without the Philadelphia fusion we
actually moved from the other side of
the planet to be here to cast this lis
we've been talking about it for a long
time it's great to finally be here and
get things started and a great match to
start things off with with Florida
mayhem vs San Francisco shock and DotA's
of majors and minors continued while
csgo teams got ready for the Boston
major I just want to thank everyone that
came here live watching it everyone
watching in a stream for us this is so
much more than the game and you're also
a big part of why you make these spots
so great so thank you very much 2017 was
a transition year for eSports it's
impossible to say exactly where we'll go
next and no one knows where it's going
but 2017 proved that eSports has gotten
huge - huge not to have massive scandals
and business deals gone wrong but also
too huge to not treat players well and
grow leagues into something that
benefits everyone involved eSports is
here to stay
it just remains to be seen what it will
look like in 2018 thanks for watching if
you want more great content be sure to
hit that subscribe button